let's study the transformer architecture
this video is the introductory video to
the encoders
decoders and encoder decoder series of
videos
in the series we'll try to understand
what makes a transformer network
and will try to explain it in simple
high-level terms
no advanced understanding of neural
networks is necessary
but an understanding of basic vectors
and tensors may help
to get started we'll take up this
diagram from the original transformer
paper
entitled attention is all you need by
vasuami at al
as we'll see here we can leverage only
some parts of it according to what we're
trying to do
we want to dive into the specific layers
building up that architecture but we'll
try to understand
the different ways this architecture can
be used
let's first start by splitting that
architecture into two parts
on the left we have the encoder and on
the right the decoder
these two can be used together but they
can also be used independently
let's understand how these work the
encoder accepts inputs that represent
text it converts this text these words
into numerical representations
these numerical representations can also
be called embeddings or features
we'll see that it uses the
self-attention mechanism as its main
component
and we recommend you check out the video
on encoders specifically
to understand what is this numerical
presentation as well as how it works
we'll study the self-attention mechanism
in more detail as well as its
bi-directional properties
the decoder is similar to the encoder it
can also accept
text inputs it uses a similar mechanism
as the encoder
which is the masked self-attention as
well it differs from the encoder due to
its united directional feature
and is traditionally used in an
auto-regressive manner
here too we recommend you check out the
video on decoders especially to
understand how all of this works
combining the two parts results in what
is known as an encoder decoder or a
sequence to sequence transformer
the encoder accepts inputs and computes
a high level representation of those
inputs
these outputs are then passed to the
decoder the decoder uses the encoder's
outputs alongside
other inputs to generate a prediction
and then predict an output
which is what we use in future
iterations hence the term autoregressive
finally to get an understanding of
encoders decoders as a whole
we recommend you check out the video on
encoder decoders